oh j'ai un bon pressentiment à propos de ces
donjons de dragons, c'est que
le voyage du héros classique, nous avons un groupe hétéroclite
de Misfits
où nous devons combattre des dragons et des
sorciers maléfiques afin de sauver le monde, alors
comment pouvons-nous retirer cela euh comprendre
autour d'un verre,
il s'agit probablement de trouver votre propre héros à l'intérieur
et chaque personnage a sa propre version
de ce voyage
lui a fait
voir maintenant exactement ce que vous apportez à cela Je suis un
planificateur Je fais des plans Je ne serai pas
complice de l'utilisation illicite  du mauvais
butin de Gotham, quelqu'un d'autre peut-il monter à côté
de ce gars, je pense qu'il a un sens de l'humour méchant à
travers cela et cela nous permet de nous
amuser autant que possible avec cela,
je suis content qu'il soit de notre côté les nuances
que chaque acteur individuel  apporte est
ce qui rend ce film si génial
ce que je vous donne maintenant en ayant confiance que vous
êtes protégé de votre vie même
Je
tiendrai ça
[Musique]
Je fais partie du sable impitoyable des voleurs
mais il n'est pas aussi diabolique que les sorciers rouges
ne l'ont jamais mis  ta confiance en un
escroc  les ungeons et Dragons World ont des
créatures incroyables dans celui-ci, je pense
qu'ils se sont surpassés,
ces créatures sont folles, vous
pouvez vraiment dire qu'elles ont mis beaucoup de choses
là-dedans, c'est encore une heure là-bas
[Musique
] c'est juste un film très amusant qui en
fait un super  aventure avec des personnages
qui vont vous intéresser nous
voulons leur donner le film qu'ils
espéraient c'est ce que j'ai dit
ouais c'est assez dur à cuire
[Musique]